we continue this half hour with the
disruption of life and missions because
of the coronavirus pandemic
and that includes the fight against
plastic pollution some bans on the use
of plastic bags were quickly tossed out
and suddenly personal protective gear
was everywhere
now many of those objects are showing up
in fields lakes rivers
and oceans here and in nations around
the world
roxanna saveri has the story
on the shores of southwest england emily
stevenson has spent
more than a decade cleaning up trash
last year she showed us what she
typically discovers
i think we're definitely finding more
plastic bottles and
well more plastics in general but as the
covet 19 pandemic has spread
she's been finding a new kind of plastic
pollution
single-use masks and gloves
171 plastic gloves
surrounding one supermarket in the
southwest
of england how long can this stuff stay
in the environment
it quite often will get saturated when
it's in the marine environment so the
gloves will get filled with water
or the face masks just get so sodden
that they will just sink
to the bottom and once the plastic and
the this debris is on the sea
uh the sea floor there's no telling how
long it's gonna stay there for
from the u.s to europe and
asia plastic linked to the pandemic is
piling up
and now we have this to contend with
it's adding to the roughly 300 million
tons of plastic waste the un says
is produced every year most of which
ends up as litter and landfill
99 of plastics is made from fossil fuels
and we know that they are a major
contributor to climate change natalie
fee runs a non-profit in england called
city to see
campaigning against plastic pollution
and these aren't recyclable because
they're different types of plastic
whereas with a reusable mask you can
wear it multiple times you can put it in
the wash at the end of the day
for the average person like me the
reusable one is exactly
just wash it every night exactly you can
just throw it in your washing machine
throw it in with your clothes
but single-use plastic is also surging
in other ways
deliveries wrapped in plastic have
soared
coffee shops like starbucks have
temporarily stopped filling reusable
cups
and some u.s cities and states suspended
or postponed bans on plastic shopping
bags
the plastics industry has lobbied for
these roll backs
arguing that single-use plastic is the
safest material to protect
people from covet 19. tony radeshevsky
ceo of the us-based plastics
industry organization has called on the
department of health to speak out
against
bans on these products as a public
safety risk
but the world health organization has
stated the virus can survive on plastic
for up to three days
actually it's not been proven to be any
safer
than reusables
groups like city to see are promoting
ways to avoid single-use plastics in the
pandemic
would you be able to take the lid off of
it for example by reducing contact with
customers at coffee shops like this
and emily says despite the mounting
plastic trash
she's still hopeful about the future
communities
all over the world are still so engaged
and they still
want to fight this maybe even more than
before
now that many people have reconnected
with nature during lockdowns
she believes they'll try harder to
protect it
for cbs this morning saturday roxanna
suberi
london it's like this tricky balancing
act because obviously people have
concerns and trying to do the safe thing
but then there is all that new plastic i
see a lot of those masks by the way
walking around
absolutely all over the streets you know
there are going to be some unintended
consequence the question is how long it
takes to fix no doubt